c'est toujours leur de barbarie ça avec
bravo loto le jeu 100% gratuit qui peut
changer ta vie
téléchargez l'appli jeter gris et tente
de remporter jusqu'à un million d'euros
sans rien faire bravo l'auto facile
d'être riche
padam padam on arrive moi magal et moore
sac à dos paname paname on arrive à moi
mes rêves et mes chansons bien moi je
tombe amoureux de toi tu t'es tombe
amoureux de nantes a fait là il ya juste
un corps que ça passait rien trop me tue
mesure combien simone à 78,78 de sa race
est très grand pour moi non ça va c'est
réacteur après un ou deux lumbago mais
c'est rien mais voilà m et 100 et je
vous vois grave ensemble et nous
rallyman bien sûr et de joie si vous
n'étiez pas avec le corse
ah oui tout à fait comme un enfant abîmé
dans un des cas réanimer dis moi comment
maison blanche met dans la machine
[Musique]
c'est ni oui ni non
ça veut dire que si vous dites oui ou
non je vais parler avec vous pendant une
minute
on veut croquer dans un oignon d'accord
c'était qui votre concurrent le plus
dangereux dans the voice
je sais pas s'il y avait de quoi non
s'est jamais vu en temps non non il a
dit laissez passer média non je sais pas
il croque l'oignon mon slim à la nuit du
haut de ma tour la tête dans les étoiles
mais lendemain l'école
[Musique]
maman me disait fais tes devoirs
vieux-condé attend de moi
il faisait lire chacun de mes poèmes un
jour à crypter papa je te dirai que je
n'aime pas ce que c'est
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]